that's what normally happens we don't
have very good deterrence in this
country when it comes to animal cruelty
you know and to be banned from keeping
animals usually that means another
member of the family will keep them
instead in a few weeks they're out the
the fines are when you consider how much
they're making a week from selling these
sick dine puppies which is 8,000 pounds
a week there's no real fine that
justifies it unfortunately so once again
no real deterrence and the system in
this country allows this to happen time
and time again how common is it it's
incredibly common i mean there's a 1951
piece of legislation which is the pet
shop license really that doesn't mean
retail high street pet shops can do this
but people's houses garden centers
anyone who wants to really can actually
apply for one of these licenses and use
their front room as a pet shop it allows
people to buy in young puppies and then
sell them on so we have a huge problem
in this country with third party puppy
sales but usually born on puppy farms
either in Ireland Wales or now as we're
seeing increasingly in Eastern Europe
lie lithuania it's a massive problem
because there's a massive demand for
puppies so what we need to do is
reeducation tree if you want a puppy you
have to see it interacting with its mum
or better still go to a rescue center
get a rescue dog you say I mean I've
recently bought a new puppy and I saw
him with his mom but you know if that
isn't always possible is it because
sometimes mummery rejects the puppies or
whatever so what it what are the one of
the golden rules regarding Rosalie is
very very rare for for a mum to reject a
puppy really k the golden rule is to
always see the puppy interacting with
the mother you'll never get that on a
puppy farm or a private dealer or a pet
shop because the mothers won't be there
you know the motors will be hundreds of
miles away so you go to the Kennel Club
Website preferably they're assured
breeders you will see the mum
interacting with the mum be very aware
of fake mums being brought out and don't
feel that you have to rescue a pup just
because it looks sick often you know
it'll be a case of just enticing the
prospective dog owner to a property
waiting for them to clap eyes on a puppy
it may not be the one advertised it may
not even be the right breed but
soon as the prospective owner has seen
that puppy they're more likely to buy it
and if it looks sick they're more likely
to rescue it to try not to get there in
the first place we have a huge problem
in this country with online pet
advertising there are no rules so you
can advertise any animal you like so
it's very easy to get images and cute
pictures of puppies to entice people to
these properties and once they're there
they end up having to buy a puppy so
really the golden rule always see the
puppy with its mum or as I say you know
you must think about rescue dogs these
are bargains their new two chips their
toilet trained there are all different
ages and breeds please contact your
local rescue centre and save a life I
can't emphasize that enough how can the
government help well the government can
help by listening to public opinion I
mean no one wants puppies and pet shops
anymore I didn't need petition last year
they've got a hundred thousand
signatures it went to the main chamber
of the House of Commons it was debated
the overall victory for the backbench
mps however the government front bench
still thought that puppies and pet shops
was acceptable it's not appropriate
anymore in this day and age it sort of
defies all Animal Welfare Act that was
called the five freedoms their welfare
freedoms it's outdated legislation and
we really need Defra the government
department responsible for animal
welfare needs a complete overhaul of the
legislation to bring it up to date with
online to bring up to date with what we
know now the developing puppy needs and
it's certainly not to be stuck in a box
in the pet shop or to be imported from
Lithuania and then sold on from a
private address pretty much like this
this case that we're looking at today
okay let's hope that the Deaf were
listening is good to tortures always
mark thanks very much to do for joining
us on Sky News this afternoon again